Hey, what's up guys today? I'm hanging out with John from Boardshorts TV
He's got something that I wanted for years, but never got and that's a silver play button check it out
Oh there it is
The idea here today is to take the silver play button
To make a mold [that] we can turn into gummy candies chocolate or basically anything that we want or buttons so as long as John
Is cool with us ripping open his award no guarantees
We'll get this thing back in one piece
[but] I've got insurance on it was cool when the bracket screws are removed
You [can] basically slide the whole top right off and if we get lucky you know nice John's button wait stop. Talk to my [father]
You know what you can do is like modify this into a belt bub wouldn't that be sweet like check out my hope that would
Actually [book] right there. Yeah, [do] check that it works. It works. That would be a cooler belt buckle. [I] forgot to mention
This is a guy that invented CVX live in Salt Lake City a really cool event and I'll probably be there next year
What John's got here is a plastic called hdpe that's high-density polyethylene stuff
I have over here is point zero to styrene this big black sheet here is
0.004 abs and abs is supposed to be really good for vacuum forming to vacuum mold this thing. I already see a problem
We've got these little nubs here
So we're gonna have to take a grinder and shave those off and then use the belt sander to get all flat
really, but I think there might be a way around then that's just by using a little bit of dollar-store Foam board and the Styro-slicer'
Maybe we can push this thing down through carve around the edge have a really clean button to use
Okay, so here's the idea guys John's just got a couple holes in this foam that should accommodate these little rivets
[they're] what's really impressive as you can see it almost lines up perfectly flush
We press this flat turn on the foam cutter, and we're going to cut a clean line all the way around this button
I'll have to do now is take a sounding sponge and kind of clean up some of these edges to get rid of that jagged
Styrofoam and the rest should be pretty easy
We're basically just going to take the frame for our vacuum former staple some plastic to it stick it in the oven
And stick it on our back end for my machine
So much sure what we're doing here. So now we got the styrofoam reinforced
I think this is ready to vacuum [form] [for] that
We're going to need a vacuum forming machine, but it doesn't have to be something complicated
It could be as simple as this one that I made five years ago, you see
I just hacked it out of scrap wood and some perfboard and [reinforced] it with duct tape to help keep it airtight
[this] was inspired by a project. I saw by [Kipkay] about five years ago. We did a video for make magazine
[I] got a big old dusty shot back that I use this thing is 16 gallons
6.25 horsepower, so it's got a lot of suck
You can see it takes a bit to get it in there
And that's not moving and that's going to suck all the air through these holes and only cares about the amount of suckage, okay?
So here's the [idea]. We got our button reinforced. It's going to go on top of the vacuum former
We're going to get a little bit of plastic
[we] [can] staple around the top put it in an oven and warm it up until it gets saggy
They're going to flip it over put it on top of the play button and turn the vacuum on
Look, it's already starting to get soft in here. You can see around all the staples
It's starting to wrinkle you ready John standing by right here. We go
Initiate suckage
Hey check that out guys stealing that John. What do you think that's beautiful take your position?
Check this out guy that suction worked out really really well it left the play button looking fantastic
[pull] this up here
You see actually the button still stuck in there
I'm surprised the styrofoam isn't melting with how hot that is but look how beautiful that comes out guys can initiate suckage
That thing is so durable. [that's] like what our fourth mold nicely done John boom [all]
[right] guys, we're doing it
We're going to try the hDpe it's a little bit opaque at first but once it heats up and starts drooping
It'll turn clear. This is our first round. Let's see what happens
[Kahlan's] I've been in the way longer than the styrene. I wonder if we should turn the temperature better to temperature Rap pizza pizza temperature
Our hDpe has not gone clear yet. That is sagging down about two inches
so I think we're just going to go ahead and throw it on the former and see how it does at this state before we
push it any Further
Initiating
Wow, so hdpe obviously takes a lot longer to set up it actually sucked the plastic right through the holes there
So we lost a bit [of] our suction. I thought for sure that foam would have melted. [oh], yeah look at that
It's all like wrinkly on the inside. It's a little bit flimsier
- all right let's throw a sheet of abs [as] a last experiment and Collagen
Can't imagine this stuff is Gonna work. [oh]
[droopy] Crap, okay ready
[oh], yes
Yeah, and so we're heating this up at 450 [degrees] Fahrenheit. [how] long did that take like two minutes?
[you] know I was quick. I was surprised that we got a black play button check out the other side
[oh] yeah, but this is what I love is I love the texture on the front of that button. [no], that's cool
So there you go guys that's how to use a few simple materials to vacuum cast your own candy molds at home with styrene
abs hdpe alright guys thanks so much for hanging out with us today big thanks to John for coming out here and
Sacrificing his silver play button for my cause John I promise
I will fix this for you at some point in [time]
But I'm going [to] use it to make a bunch more molds first and maybe even try casting some chocolates with it as well
They try me out [brad] has been fun. It's been a blend and he's got a channel called Boardshorts TV
It's super super awesome. Five hundred thousand [subscribers]. They basically have kids tell stories, and then they act along to the stories
Hey guys, thanks so much for joining us for this experiment. We'll be looking for your next project video. Talk to you then